the Beetlejuice game is simple Jason let
me play a sample this one doesn't count
you don't have any pressure on you
whatsoever so here I'm gonna play for
you here's what we asked beetle there we
go
we're off to a rousing start fathe
phooey off with your head well it is on
track 1 but beetles answering the
question is what I should just give you
the money Jason this isn't good this is
gonna end up in me yelling you Gary and
it's gonna be a disaster
[ __ ] what's going on here Sal told you
you check what Sal tells you haven't we
learned over the years that Sal telling
you something is as good as that wall
telling me something where are you going
Gary Gary just left
Sal was like the first track was in the
middle of a pause if you go back to 1
you'll hear me ask the question alright
so so it was queued up the wrong way yes
so it's Gary's fault
right no I'm not saying I'm saying it is
well who cued it up I didn't play it I
put it in and I put it on track 1 it's
not queued up
I don't know but I don't know if
somebody touched it I guess has you
tested it and I did not I don't touch
that you agree Sal no just gave me the
thumbs-up of course you did who cued it
up you its cued up wrong no no I put
hold on seriously stop it leave him
alone what's the matter with you what
are you hitting him for just hit him
what are you doing just says he agrees
with me I'm not gonna sit here stand
behind me act like a dick he's gonna get
a kick in the balls no you know he's not
didn't get the [ __ ] out he didn't do
anything that's [ __ ] I'm here to be
his [ __ ] tool first of all don't kick
anyone around here don't [ __ ] with me
he's that [ __ ] way yes he is he
agrees with me I'm [ __ ] with you
I don't don't need a timeout like when
my kids time out get out of here I'm
telling you need a time history of
course I'm just gonna give you a time
I'm gonna answer the question I'm gonna
answer the timeout
I want you sit in your office for 15
minutes until I put the disc and said
you have it I never touch one telling me
as a time I hear you
Akihiro - oh you mean added to
emasculating I'd give you freedom to
emasculate this [ __ ] but go
ahead give him a timeout timeout okay
you have to go put the disc in what it
sounds right el him again I don't bow to
him tre I said timeout please leave I
did not thank you I put this on spend 15
minutes in your office and send in will
to be my producers because he doesn't
seem to screw up what the hell's the
matter with that idiot are you all right
Gary could kick me all day long I break
his balls so much it's completely fine
all right he's a good guy stupid bugger
[Laughter]
I'm sorry Robin I had to give Gary a
timeout I see they're acting like kids
he was acting like a child